did you think that it was even possible
to make gold star widows a partisan
issue or did you think that it was
possible to make sexual harassment and
possible sexual assault a partisan issue
well if you thought not you're wrong
welcome to America 2017 everything sucks
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show happy monday gang yeah that's right
welcome back from the weekend and as we
come back from the weekend it turns out
the presidents of the United States is
now in an open running gun battle with a
Goldstar Widow which is these this may
the second time that he's decided to do
this particular thing we had this last
time at the Republican at the Democratic
National Convention when the con family
decided to go political in this case
there's a woman in my Isha Johnson her
husband 'la David Johnson was killed in
in Nigeria Niger neither pronounced it
everyone's pronouncing it differently
I'll call it Niger because I speak
English and in any case the the the
widow went on Good Morning America and
ripped into president Trump and
president Trump respondents who will
talk about all of those things plus we
will talk about Bill O'Reilly a big
story came out over the weekend
suggesting that he had paid 32mm a
million dollars for a sexual harassment
suit to settle it out of court that is a
lot of money to pay someone if the
allegations are not credible in any case
we will talk about all of those things
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriots apply so if
it feels like the world is about to end
that's because it might be it might be
not like apocalyptic fire and flame but
it is possible that there will be a
natural disaster that strikes in your
area it's possible there'd be a
terrorist attack it's possible that you
just won't be able to get to the grocery
store for some reason and people can't
get to you and so instead what you need
is a food supply that ensures that you
and your family are safe that's why you
need to go over to my friends in my
Patriot supply get their 102 serving
survival food kit for just $99 includes
breakfast lunches and dinners and it
shipped to your home for free order that
kit and it keeps your family safe for
like 25 years it lasts up to 25 years in
storage apparently taste like home
cooking so I've been told by the folks
here around the office call 888 803 1413
888 803 1413 or go online to prepare
with Ben's comm again for 99 bucks get a
hundred and two servings of survival
food for just $99 it's one of the things
that lets even
government says you should have food on
hand so that you don't have to worry in
case there's an emergency go make your
family safe with one purchase and then
you don't have to think about it until
the emergency actually hits 888 803 1413
or prepare with been calm again prepare
with been calm okay
so I have a lot to talk about today and
a lot of it is based around the idea
that partisanship has completely eaten
our politics to the point where basic
facts are no longer worthy of
consideration so let's consider a
scenario let's start with President
Trump and this in this Widow
Myesha Johnson let's talk about the
possibility that we have what I've
called before a Rashomon situation I'm
not the person who coined that term ok
the Rashomon situation it's a movie by
Kurosawa
and in Rashomon basically there's a
murder that takes place and there are
four people who see the murder but they
all have a different recollection
because they were in different places at
the time they all have a different
recollection of how the murder went down
who's responsible how the murder was
caused and so this has become known as
sort of Rashomon situation in this
particular case there's high potential
for a Rashomon situation where President
Trump calls up a Goldstar Widow the
Goldstar Widow it sounds like was
probably politically oriented against
Trump to begin with she and her family
were very close with Frederica Wilson
this Democratic Congress person from
Florida who's very much on the left and
who's talked about impeaching Trump for
months and the the congresswoman was
present when Trump decided to call the
widow of Sargent latavia Johnson
remember Allah David Johnson was killed
in Niger or nice year was killed in
October 4th in a mission went wrong his
body went missing for some 48 hours and
we still don't know how he died publicly
in any case the the congresswoman said
that Trump had been really kind of cold
during the call that Trump hadn't
remembered the name of the of the
soldier who was killed that Trump had
said something to the effect of he knew
what he was signing up for the
implication being you know he knew he
might die so big deal and then John
Kelly came out last week and said listen
I was present for the phone call -
that's not what he said what he said was
he was a brave man
knowing that this is what you signed up
for which is a completely different read
now it is completely possible because
this happens all the time it's happened
in your own life that a conversation
happened and two people took away
precisely the opposite views of what the
conversation was
all right you've had this with spouses
you've had this with family members
where you say something you think is
completely innocuous and it is taken in
the most offensive possible way that is
just one of the ways that the language
works that's the vagary of language and
if you go into a conversation with the
precondition with the pre notion that
the person you're talking to is opposed
to you the person doesn't like you then
it's possible to read their words in the
worst possible way that's what I
actually think happened here I don't
think President Trump called up a widow
of soldier and decided to be cold and
calculating and cruel I don't think he
even intended to do that I didn't think
that he in ignorance would do that that
doesn't sound like President Trump I
mean I've been very very critical of
President Trump but even that one is a
bridge too far for me that said it's
certainly possible for the widow to take
that away from the conversation so yes
it this morning on Good Morning America
the widow finally appears and from at
this point we've only heard from the
mother-in-law or really the the aunt of
the of the soldier who was killed we've
heard from Frederica Wilson we've heard
from John Kelly but we hadn't heard from
the principal's in the conversation
right Trump said that this e that he
hadn't said any of this but now you have
the widow coming out in the widow says
here's exactly how it went down here she
is with George Stephanopoulos on ABC
News the questions that I have that I
need answered is I want to know why I
took them 48 hours to find my husband
why couldn't I see my husband every time
I asked to see my husband they wouldn't
let me there are also a lot of questions
about the phone call you received from
President Trump I know you were in a car
to the airport tell us what happened
next what he said was the president yes
the president said that he knew what he
signed up for but it hurts anyways and I
was it made me cry because I was very
angry at the tone of his voice in hi he
said he couldn't remember my husband
name the only way he remember my husband
name because he told me he had my
husband report in front of him and
that's when he actually said blah David
so her suggestion is that her husband
Lee David Johnson
that Trump didn't actually know the name
of the person that he was talking about
so Trump immediately jumps to Twitter
and starts tweeting about it again does
any of is this any is this useful in any
way is there any usefulness to this at
all of course not
there's no usefulness to this so Trump
tweets out I had a very respectful
conversation with the widow of Sergeant
Lee David Johnson and spoke his name
from beginning without hesitation why
why let's let's say the Trump is
completely right here is this a fight he
wants to get into a fight with the woman
who just lost her husband in tragic
situation while he was serving as an
American Hero is this a fight he really
wants to do is this a political winning
fight now I know that there are a lot of
people on the right who do the he fights
routine he fights he fights he fights
again punching yourself in the balls
isn't fighting okay this is not smart
it's just not smart it's also not classy
okay it's not classy to fight with war
widows she's a general rule okay I have
a general rule and this caramelised the
problem everything can be made partisan
because sure it's true that Trump can
feel that he is justified in fighting
back if he feels like he is being fibbed
about sure Trump has every right to
speak how he wants to speak there's the
First Amendment in the country but it is
also true that we had a certain basic
agreement in the country and that was
that the President of the United States
ought to have a fair bit of respect for
war widows even ones who disagree with
him so what what
maisha johnson is saying here is nothing
even close to as bad as what cindy
sheehan said about george w bush if you
don't remember back to 2005 there was a
woman named cindy sheehan her son was
killed in iraq
she was a far-left code pink person I
think she's one of the founders of code
pink actually and cindy sheehan
was a vocal critic of the Iraq war and
she condemned Bush as a war criminal she
suggested it was his fault that her son
had died Bush actually met with her and
then she complained he hadn't met with
her
but how did Bush respond so I want to
show you video of President George HW
Bush because it turns out that honest to
goodness if you want a country that
holds together you know he talked a lot
about character these past two years and
some people have said what's the use of
character all we need is the policy does
the character really matter does the
character of the President of the United
States really make a difference and this
has been a serious conversation in the
country really since the days of Bill
Clinton who had no character right does
character matter in the Oval Office and
the answer is yes the reason character
matters in the Oval Office is for the
same reason that character matters in
or day to day life the people that make
you feel like you can lead a cohesive
life the people who make you feel like
you live in a community what creates
social capital is character social
capital as Robert Putnam the the
political scientist from Harvard has
said social capital is the idea that as
a society we all have a certain given
amount of trust in one another that
allows us to act as though the other
person is not going to screw us all the
time so the higher your social capital
actually the less you need contracts
right the more lawyers you need that's a
good indication that you don't have a
lot of social capital because why do I
sign a contract with somebody I sent a
contract with somebody and I'm very
meticulous about that contracts I'm
afraid they're gonna break it so I have
a contract with my children I have a
marital contract with my wife but it's
pretty short sweet document right that
everyone has that in the Jewish
communities called ketubah but the idea
is that most of your major relationships
in life you don't have a contract why
because your social capital is really
high right you have trust in that person
it's just a longer way of saying trust
and if we don't trust each other to have
a generalized sense of what's
appropriate and what's not a generalized
sense for what is sacred and what's not
then you're gonna end up in these
running gun battles over stupidity every
single day and you're gonna be
attributing to the other person bad
motives all the time so cindy sheehan as
i said was really quite horrible the
President Bush I mean she again accused
him of being a war criminal suggested
that he had got in America into the war
in Iraq based on explicit lies that he
lied because he wanted to go to war in
Iraq that he was solely responsible for
the death of her son here's how George W
Bush responded to Cindy she had making
all of these allegations in Crawford
Texas I'm referring to any grieving
mother or father no matter what their
political views may be part of my duty
as the president is to meet with those
who've lost a loved one and so you know
listen I sympathize with mrs. Sheehan
she feels strongly about her about her
position and I she has every right in
the world to say what she believes this
is America she has a right to her
position and I've thought long and hard
about her position I've heard her
position from others which is get out of
Iraq now and
it it would be a it would be a mistake
for the security of this country and the
ability to lay the foundations for peace
in the long run if we were to do so okay
and this is who george w bush was this
is why i have a lot of respect for bush
the man as i said i disagreed with him
on a lot of policy but this is a classy
individual who is in the white house i
mean there's a story that the dana
perino told i don't remember if i
actually told it i think i referred to
it the other day but here's the actual
story that dana perino told about george
w bush visiting a grieving mother and
it's pretty amazing so here here it is
he visited a patient at walter reed
medical facility and right there there
was there's one situation in which one
mom and dad of a dying soldier from the
caribbean were devastated the mom beside
herself with grief that's from dana
perino circa 2016 it was in her book she
yelled at the president wanting to know
why it was her child and not his who lay
in that hospital bed her husband tried
to calm her and I noticed the president
wasn't in a hurry to leave he tried to
offer in comfort but just stood there
and took it like he expected and needed
to hear the anguish to try to soak up
some of her suffering if he could later
as we rode back on marine one to the
White House no one spoke but as the
helicopter took off the president looked
at me and said that mama sure was mad at
me then he turned to look out the window
of the helicopter and I don't blame her
a bit a terrace looked out at the side
of his irons down his face he didn't
wipe it away and we flew back to the
White House
okay that's what creates trust in a
country I may disagree with Bush on a
particular war I may disagree with Obama
on a particular war that if I don't
believe that Obama believes that people
who clearly have good motivations you
know the families of people who have
died in Iraq or died in Afghanistan or
died in Nigeria that those people have
bad motivations those people have to be
attacked that those people it doesn't
matter what they say politically at
least when it comes to their child or
their family member their husband their
wife those people have the right
motivations we cannot have a country
with social capital where we trust each
other if we're not willing to take the
hit once in a while if we're not willing
to go out there and say as did the Trump
should have just said here's what Trump
should have said you said listen as the
person on the other end of the
conversation
I did not think that that was what I was
saying if that's how it was taken then I
fully apologized but I don't believe
that's what I said I would never try to
be callous I would never
million years try to be callous to
anyone whose husband had served the the
country with such honor and distinction
as sergeant Johnson did I would never do
that if it was read that way then I
fully apologized and I'm more than happy
to meet with the widow and talk with her
and try and clear the air because I
think that it's important that we all be
on the same page here we all know what a
hero her husband was instead of doing
that he's busy tweeting about how this
isn't how it happened how is that
helpful how is that helpful and again
you can say that Trump is just telling
the truth but it's not helpful to him if
you want him to succeed as president it
isn't he must have social capital with
the American public if you want him to
succeed if you want him to be reelected
understand not everything Trump does not
every fight he picks is a winning fight
if you would pick a few fewer of these
fights he would be better off you know I
think that there's this this certain
sense that'sthat's set in on the right
and it's set on on the left - and it's
very weird okay there's this sense
that's set in on the right that no
matter what Trump does he is utterly
untouchable because after all he was hit
with everything including the kitchen
sink in the 2016 election cycle and he
won anyway and so therefore he can do
and say whatever he wants and he's never
gonna lose his base and he's not gonna
lose another election because after all
he beat Hillary Clinton so why would he
lose another election
this'n elects one well two really
important facts one George W Bush in
2000 lost the popular ball by 500,000 he
barely won the election right by 2004
when he beat John Kerry by about a
million and a half two million votes
he had picked up ten million votes
between 2000 and 2004 he picked up ten
million votes and he picked up a lot of
those votes because in 9/11 and the war
in Iraq he picked up ten million and the
only one by two so where is President
Trump gonna come up with a thirteen
million votes he's gonna need to win
remember he lost by almost 3 million
popular votes in this election cycle so
that's problem number one for for this
perspective problem number two is he's
not gonna be running against Hillary
Clinton again now maybe the Democrats
are stupid enough this is the other side
of the coin maybe the Democrats are
stupid enough to run somebody who is as
unpopular as Hillary Clinton maybe they
decide they need to run Elizabeth Warren
or Kamala Harris maybe they decided to
be that dumb maybe they decide that they
want to recreate Obama's intersectional
coalition and they fail again
but Republicans shouldn't be counting on
that okay Democrats seem to be counting
on the fact
Trump has low approval ratings to mean
that Trump is gonna lose in 2020 that's
idiotic
Trump had the same approval ratings now
that he had before and he won an
approval ratings don't mean a thing
because he's running against someone
writes a binary election as we learned
as we were told a thousand times is
binary so that means the Democrats are
gonna have to come up with somebody they
can't just rail on Trump all day and
hope to win by the same terms Trump
can't hope to do whatever he wants to do
and increase his approval rating and win
reelection just by default because
that's not how this is gonna work now I
want to talk a little bit more about
things becoming partisan that absolutely
should not be partisan in just a second
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Birch gold so right now
things feel relatively uncertain the
stock market is up so as the price of
gold but the fact is that there are a
lot of people who suggest the stock
market may be in a bubble the real
estate market very much looks like it's
in a bubble that's why you should at
least be diversified into precious
metals so part of my vast fortune is in
precious metals and if you are going to
invest in precious metals then you need
to trust the people that I trust the
folks over at Birch gold group right now
thanks to a little-known IRS tax law you
can move your IRA or eligible 401k into
a into a IRA or 401k backed by physical
gold and silver without IRS consequences
Birch gold group has a long-standing
track record of continued success
thousands of satisfied clients countless
five-star reviews a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau contact Birch
gold group right now to get a
comprehensive 16 page kit showing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
and how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA again that's
birchgold.com slash been birchgold.com
slash men make sure you use the slash
bin so you get that comprehensive 16
page free kit and also so that they know
that we sent you birchgold.com slash Ben
okay so with all of this said I want to
talk about the the self assurance of
President Trump and the assurance of the
Democrats that all they have to do is
attack Trump and then they can win and
then I want to talk a little bit about
sexual harassment and the polarization
regarding that okay so here is the the
what I think is foolish self assurance
of President Trump that he can basically
do whatever he wants and get away with
it because so far who's been able to do
whatever he wants and get away with it
here's President Trump talking about his
use of Twitter I have
that say uh don't use social media see I
don't call it tweets a tweeting is like
a typewriter when I put it out you put
it immediately on your show I mean the
other day I put something out two
seconds later I'm watching your show
it's watching and you know they're
well-crafted I was always a good student
I'm like the person that does well with
that kind of thing and I doubt I'd be
here of a war for social media to me I'm
not gonna Mock the statement that he's a
great student he was a good student
who's always someone who did well with
that sort of thing
like he's a smart person okay I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna spend too much time
on that or the fact that he had three
different spellings of the word council
before he got it right
okay but beyond that you know the self
assurance that that his Twitter is what
sets the agenda listen it's true his
Twitter does set the agenda which is why
he should be careful about how he uses
it again this is not coming from a place
where I want to see Trump fail you think
I wanted to stop tweeting so that Hill
is that he'll fail I wanted to stop
tweeting so that he'll succeed as
president I wanted to stop tweeting so
he's not getting in useless fights okay
so this is the problem on the right the
problem on the right is a bunch of
people on the right thing Trump can do
whatever he wants and he'll get away
with it because after all he's been able
to so far and then there's the problem
on the left the left has two choices in
2020 again I'm not in the business of
giving advice to the left the left has
two choices in 2020 they can either
recognize that they lost in 2020 in 2016
and have been losing for the past
several years several election cycles
because they have remade their base or
they can continue to try and go back to
the well so there is the Clinton base
from 1990 to 1996 and then there is the
base and then there is the base from
Barack Obama in 2000 2012 completely
different coalition very very different
coalition now first of all if Democrats
think that Trump is weak going into 2020
they're neglecting the fact that one
count'em one president since 1968 has
not won reelection right without a
significant third-party candidacy
i George George HW Bush only loses
because Perot is there but every other
president has won two terms in office
except for Jimmy Carter because Jimmy
Carter was so freaking awful and even
Carter heads run against one of the
great candidates in American history
Ronald Reagan in order for him to lose
in what was a close election up to the
very end okay so for Democrats to
suggest that Trump is is weak here is
foolish on their part
they have two choices one they can try
to remake the Bill Clinton coalition
then go after those blue-collar voters
nominate somebody like Joe Biden
somebody like Bernie Sanders go after
the voters in Michigan that Hillary
Clinton lost and couldn't drive out they
will have to acknowledge that Hillary
was garbage candidate
they'll have to acknowledge that Hillary
was a terrible terrible candidate and
the real reason that Trump is president
is not because Trump is good at this
it's because Hillary was quite awful at
this while the Democrats don't want to
accept this
okay the proof is in the statistics
Hillary Clinton let's wear this way
Donald Trump won fewer votes in
Wisconsin in 2016 than Mitt Romney did
in 2012 Romney lost the state in a walk
Trump won the state no one showed up to
vote for Hillary Clinton Donald Trump
when fewer votes in Michigan then george
w bush did in 2004 Bush lost the state
of Michigan Trump won it in a walk no
one voted for Hillary Clinton she stunk
okay they thought that they could just
remake the Obama coalition they could
just go back to the well with this old
white lady and it didn't work that way
they figured okay if we lose a few black
voters a few Hispanic voters no big deal
we can just drive up the women's vote it
didn't happen that way if they decide to
go back to the well with Kamala Harris
or Elizabeth Warren because they're
going to ignore the white working-class
again they're going to ignore males or
white women who are married if they do
that they're gonna lose again so they
think that if they just attacked Trump
enough then by default they will they
will win the election I don't think that
that's true in any sense and that's why
they're making a very foolish mistake in
the same way that Trump is making a
foolish mistake by attacking Myesha
johnson the gold star widow the media
are making a very foolish mistake by
attacking General John Kelly a gold star
father so general Kelly as we discussed
last week went out there ripped
fredericka wilson ripped the media for
turning this whole gold star family
phone call thing into a fiasco again I
said everyone here deserves blame except
for I think my issue Johnson and John
Kelly I think both of them are gold star
family members and they have an added
bit of credibility here but the media
have decided to jump on General Kelly
anyway because Kelly is associated with
Trump
so Thomas Friedman who has no moral
authority I mean Thomas Friedman the
columnist from New York Times who's
basically made a career out of flying
around to various terrible countries
being put up in a hotel for a night and
then talking in glowing terms about how
wonderful the country is Thomas Friedman
says John Kelly lost moral authority
week how seriously should the public
take this what what's going on Chuck is
a real crisis of authority something I
talked about in the show once before I
quoted my friend outside and I said Joe
there's a there's a big difference
between formal Authority and moral
authority so we have a president who has
formal authority but I would argue he
has lost all of his moral authority that
is why last week he had to bring out
general Kelley four-star marine general
because he still had formal Authority
and moral authority
unfortunately general Kelley by say
things that were probably false about
that congresswoman really lost I think a
lot of his moral authority and now we
have a situation where the White House
spokeswoman had to invoke his formal
authority that he was a four-star marine
general to basically shut up the press
and I think that's the tragedy here like
everyone is lost their moral authority
and I think that's a real crisis for the
lost his moral authority but they're
talking about his general Kelley made an
allegation during that press conference
that fredericka Wilson had dedicated a
building in 2013 I believe 2012 in which
and at that dedication of an FBI
building he said she bragged about
achieving funding for the building now
if you go back and you watch the speech
which I have and I wrote a full
transcript of it she does spend about
four minutes bragging but she's not
bragging about the the building funding
she's bragging about the naming of the
building and she says that she was
chiefly responsible for the naming of
this building after these fallen FBI
agents Kelley may have gotten the
content wrong with regard to what she
was bragging about but he was right that
she spent several minutes bragging about
what a wonderful job she had done in any
case the idea that John Kelly lost his
moral authority let's put it this way is
there anyone on the left who would be
making this contention if a gold star
family on the Left had said the same
thing we were told that Cindy Sheehan
had absolute moral authority we were
told that the Jersey girls were the
widows of people killed on 9/11 had
absolute moral authority I think does a
phrase used by Maureen Dowd there's no
had absolute moral authority didn't
matter of what they were saying wasn't
true they had absolute moral authority
the idea that John Kelly lost his moral
authority because he attacked Frederico
Wilson is just ridiculous and you want
to see the partisanship in the media let
me show you Kaiser Cohn so Kaiser Khan
as you recall was the father of a Muslim
soldier who was slain in Iraq or that
thing is Iraq
Afghanistan in any case he was at the
2016 convention and he ripped down
President Trump Trump got into it with
Kaiser Khan's wife because he said
Kaiser Khan's wife was just standing
there and he has no idea why the
implication being of course that Muslim
women are silent and don't say anything
and it was a big hubbub if you don't
recall
so Kaiser Kahn now is back right he's on
Face the Nation and now he's going to
talk about why he has moral authority to
speak about politics but gold star
father John Kelly does not I was shocked
I was shocked to see citizen Kelly
standing next to the president when he
when president could not have the proper
word to condemned attack on the Blessed
city of Charlottesville Virginia by
neo-nazis he stood you could look at his
face and his gesture in disgust but he
stood in support of that moment when
Donald Trump could not condemn the
attack that took place then again
instead of advising the president that
restraint and dignity is the call of the
moment former general Kelly indulged in
defending behavior of the President and
made the situation even worse so only he
is allowed to speak politically only
he's allowed to go up there at a
Democratic National Convention and talk
about politics so again everything
becomes partisan this wasn't partisan
right this wasn't partisan just like the
NFL flag controversy was not partisan
there was basic bipartisan agreement
that kneeling for the anthem was dumb
now it's a partisan issue there's basic
bipartisan agreement the gold star
families deserve our sympathy and our
respect even if we disagree with them
politically that was destroyed last year
and now it's been destroyed even more
all of these things where we had
consensus are now gone Frederick Wilson
is openly attacking John Kelly
suggesting that Kelly was a puppet of
the president again is there anything
from her lips about the respect for gold
star families that she supposedly
signifies first of all I have to say I
don't know how many hats this woman owns
but it is astonishing I mean this is
this is a real repertoire of hats as it
had aficionado I enjoy a good hat I have
to say respects to Frederica Wilson
the unhatched not a lot of respect for
what she has done over the past week
you know John Kelly it's almost I guess
you could say he was a puppet of the
President and what he was trying to do
was divert the attention away from the
President on to me
and he basically just lied on me and I
don't like I don't appreciate people
lying on me and that's what he did
I've been in politics a long time and
most things don't bother me you know it
just rolls off my back I've been lied on
before but the character assassination
that he went through to call me out of
my name in empty barrel and all the work
that I've done in this community not
only does he owe me an apology but he
owes an apology to the American people
because when he lied on me he lied to
you first of all you should never lie on
people because that sexual assault but
beyond that you know when she says that
you know Kelly is the puppet of the
President again it's funny because Trump
attacking gold star families the end of
the world fredericka wilson attacking
gold star father that's not the again
now she can disagree with Kelly but the
way she should do it is she should say
that she should say listen I know that
general Kelly has great experience with
gold star families I respect his
experience with gold star families with
respect the wife of a of a soldier says
that she was offended by the President
of the United States
I don't see why General Kelly would
defend the president under those
circumstances or give facts that are
provably untrue about me that does not
undermine his moral authority but it
does say that just because you have
moral authority doesn't mean what you're
saying is correct on this score moral
authority on gold star families does not
necessarily translate over into other
areas right this is the way we could
have a civil decent conversation that
builds unity in the public but we're not
going to do any of those things so
before I get to sexual harassment and
sexual assault again becoming a partisan
issue I first want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Realty shares calm
is not an offering of securities private
investments are highly illiquid and
risky not suitable for all investors
past performance is not indicative of
future results securities offered to
accredited investors through North
capital private securities member finra
s ipeec so
as you get older you realize that if you
want to assure that you're going to have
retirement if you want to assure that
you're gonna be able to retire early or
that you have money in the bank you need
to invest it's not enough just to stick
your money in the bank and leave it
sitting there accruing a tiny percentage
of interest every year instead you need
to be actively investing and that is
what Realty shares does re al t Y shares
com they've destroyed the walls between
you and real estate investing you don't
need billions or millions or even tens
of thousands of dollars to invest in
vetted real estate assets so here's what
Realty shares does you go to their
website and then they have all of these
investment projects that you can take
part in for just $5,000 everyone invests
fractional ate almost like buying a
stock and you are basically investing in
this particular property it's free to
sign up in browse investments getting
set up takes a few minutes then you can
manage and invest straight from your
phone or computer through their simple
and secure online process all it takes
is five thousand bucks to make an
investment there are no hidden fees if
you make 200 thousand dollars a year you
may qualify find out today at realty
shares comm slash Ben again that's
Realty shares comm slash Ben and right
now
if you use Realty shares comm slash Ben
you get $100 toward your first
investment so instead of five thousand
it cost you forty nine hundred bucks
that's Realty shares spelled re alt Y
shares comm slash Ben for $100 toward
your first investment again Realty
shares comm slash Ben you owe it to
yourself to ensure that you have a
financial future that is secure Realty
shares comm slash Ben helps you do that
okay so again I think that everyone is
getting partisan because they think that
if they attack the personalities on the
other side they'll win Trump thinks that
if he attacks the personalities on the
other side that this will somehow boost
him the left thinks if they attack Trump
then that will boost Trump and then
they'll boost them all of this is is a
problem all of it destroys the social
fabric now listen I like aggressive
politicking I think aggressive
politicking is good but I like
aggressive politicking on the issues
I don't like aggressive politicking on
the implication that your character is
flawed because we disagree or because we
interpreted the same event two different
ways and I think that this is this is
going on sideways in a pretty
significant way another way in which
this has gone sideways and there's just
certain aspects of American life that I
feel like good people all agree on
things
alright I've said this in my speeches
you know people say there's a rape
culture and I say okay who's Pro rape
who's Pro rape like maybe the person
whose program I say this in my college
speeches all the time no who's Pro
murder who is pro racism like name the
people who are Pro racism I think racism
is a great thing aside from you know
some of the members the alt-right or
some of the members of the
intersectional left like name the people
who think racism is an awesome thing
when the answer is there not a lot of
people who believe those things but
there's a secondary problem that we do
have to talk about and that is the
feeling that even if you agree rape is a
terrible thing or even if you agree that
sexual harassment and sexual assault or
a bad thing that when it's your own side
doing it you're willing to look the
other way for the quote-unquote greater
good this is a common phenomenon it's
it's something that's fascinating to me
I think that this is actually how evil
movements get started I think that Nazi
Germany got started not because the
Nazis were clear and concise about what
they were about to do to the Jews but
because there are a lot of people who
felt like well it's a lot of friends
rhetoric that's a lot of garbage they're
saying but at least they're at least
they're better than the Communists at
least they're better than is a recipe
for you approving bad things at least
they're better than is you winking and
nodding at bad behavior in order to
justify bad behavior on your own side
because what it really should be is not
at least we're better than it should be
yes this is garbage on our side and it's
bad on the other side too it's terrible
on our side and it's terrible on the
other side so on the Left there's been
this rush to there was this rush to
condemn Donald Trump and then as soon as
it was Harvey Weinstein then everybody
hid in the closet and now there's an
avoidance of naming more names we know
we know I mean we've heard the stories
from women women are out there saying I
was sexually assaulted I was sexually
harassed they will not name the names
I'm talking about major actresses who
could afford to make this stand they're
not doing it why aren't they doing it
well in some cases there are power
relationships at stake but in some cases
there's a feeling by some people on the
left like well I'll condemn it limits
the Catholic Church but what it's
Hollywood really like do I have to go
there maybe if I just quiet down and on
the right there was this feeling about
President Trump right we were loud and
proud about how much we thought that
Bill Clinton had sexually exploited
women but when Trump bragged about it on
tape then we were like ah big deal ah
big deal a lot of people on the right
felt that way or at least they felt like
it's bad but
that bad now I'm not talking about
voting for Trump you can still vote for
Trump but you should at least have
condemned that you should release say
this is disgusting behavior what he's
talking about here like this is not
difficult and again I want to
distinguish between a couple of
different types of response to bad
behavior that I'm talking about one is
situations in which you are at the lower
end of the power imbalance so I'm not
talking about victims who are still
trying to make a career in Hollywood and
know that no one is gonna stand up with
them and that their career will be
ruined for speaking out okay I
understand the moral conundrum that
happens I know that I'm sure that there
are plenty of women who are going on
shows like Bill O'Reilly who may have
felt not good about how they were
treated but also understood that if they
spoke out about it they would never be
appearing on Bill O'Reilly's show again
right I'm sure they're women who felt
that way just as I'm sure that there are
women in Hollywood who feel like they've
been sexually assaulted or harassed by
producers and directors we know them
they're talking about it and have said
well I'm not gonna give up my career do
I really want to give them the tool to
destroy my career by going out and
saying something that isn't gonna be
tried in a court and the guy will just
continue to work you know is that a
fight I can win so there are people who
say is that a fight I can win and the
answer sometimes is no I don't really
feel a lot of blame for those people
that's group number one group number two
are people who say yes what happened
here is terrible
that doesn't make everyone in Hollywood
terrible or you know President Trump
talked about doing terrible things or
Bill Clinton talked about doing terrible
things I'm still gonna vote from because
he's better than the alternative but
that was a terrible thing not talking
about that group of people either I'm
talking about the people who say was it
really that bad was he really that bad
you know there was a story that broke
over the weekend and the story was that
that Bill O'Reilly had allegedly signed
a 32 million dollar settlement of sexual
harassment against a woman named Liz
Weil I think who was a lawyer he used to
appear on Fox News affair but thirty two
million dollars is an enormous amount of
money for anyone you know to sign a
settlement for thirty two million
dollars
it does not tend to suggest that
everything everything was evidence list
or easily disprovable at the very least
now Bill O'Reilly's fighting back
against this as you would imagine but it
obviously there is a serious problem
inside Fox News Roger Ailes had a
problem clearly you know Reilly clearly
was we had a problem
there there there were people who were
beyond that who apparently had problems
or at least they were looking the other
way because these were powerful people
now powerful people are the ones who
need to stand up powerful people are the
ones who need to stand up and say
something
so today megyn kelly came out and again
i want to show you that the partisanship
here is so incredible with regard to
megyn kelly in particular and I'll say
I'm friendly with Megan but here's what
Megan had to say about Bill O'Reilly
bill had basically come out and said
that all of this is trumped up by the
left here is megyn kelly
suggesting precisely the opposite today
however O'Reilly's suggestion that no
one ever complained about his behavior
is false I know because I complained I
wrote an email to the co-presidents of
Fox News bill shine and Jack Abernathy
an email I have never made public but
I'm sharing now because I think it
speaks volumes about powerful men and
the roadblocks one can face in taking
them on I wrote in part perhaps he
didn't realize the kind of message his
criticism sends to young women across
this country about how men continue to
view the issue of speaking out about
sexual harassment perhaps he didn't
realize that his exact attitude of
shaming women into shutting the hell up
about harassment on grounds that it will
disgrace the company is in part how Fox
News got into the decade-long ailes mess
to begin with perhaps it's his own
history of harassment of women which has
as you both know resulted in payouts to
more than one woman including recently
that blinded him to the folly of saying
anything other than I am just so sorry
for the women of this company who never
should have had to go through that so
Megan said that the response to this was
the fox brass saying they would take
care of it and then allowing O'Reilly to
go on that night and basically defend
his commentary Roger Ailes was still at
the company at that point now what are
there people inside Fox who knew what
Roger Ailes was doing let's forget a
rally for a second knew it Roger Ailes
was doing I'm sure there are people who
knew exactly what Roger Ailes
was doing I'm sure that there are people
who knew what the conditions were like
you know around Roger Ailes but if they
couldn't take down Roger Ailes then you
have a power imbalance situation but how
about all the women who didn't say
anything how about all the people who
are around Ailes who knew stuff was
going on who didn't say anything you
know this to me is the same as Harvey
Weinstein's driver who's saying that
they're women
getting into his car and you know he was
afraid to lose his job but he could have
testified about it you know this is
power is is something that corrupts and
loyalty to institutions beyond loyalty
to ideals and decency is a serious
problem and it's something I see in
politics across the board right now it
means the end of the country you know
the title of this episode is are we
looking at the end of the country it
means the end of the country we don't
have a common vision that includes a
common decency that includes a common
basic idea that bad behavior is bad
behavior whether it's somebody I like or
somebody I don't like who's performing
that bad behavior right it doesn't what
I'm seeing too much of is bad behavior
but it's on my side so a and we talked
about this a lot last year during the
election cycle and it's happened on both
sides and just cuz the other side
doesn't mean it's okay for you to do it
I see this all the time you people on
the right my principles my principles
first of all I hate this garbage this
must stuff on online yeah muh as though
you're a baby for saying my principles
I thought that the founding fathers of
this country were deeply imbued with the
sense of principle I thought that being
a religious person meant being
principled I'm not sure when principles
became an insult as opposed to something
that we're supposed to stand up for
defend and protect I'm not sure when
principles went by the wayside because
hey we're in a fight and it's a blood
match if you feel like you're in such a
blood match with the other members of
America the principles go by the wayside
they are in such an actual war that
principals are now by the wayside or
that you can't at least express publicly
I'm putting aside my principle now to
make a tactical decision to Club
everyone back in line on principle if
you can't even do that you're just
discarding them because hey principles
what do they matter in war all's fair
then we don't live in a country where
we're brothers anymore or sisters
anymore we don't live in a country where
there's any social capital or trust
anymore the prom ones principle if you
feel like your principles are now
secondary to the fight then we really
are at war or your misconstruing the
situation one of those two things okay
as we continue here on ben shapiro show
i want to talk about some republican
infighting that has been taking place i
also want to talk about some democratic
and fighting that's been taking place
and why all of this pie why of this why
this partisanship this this decision the
principle is no longer matter has some
real ramifications for how the
government is run but first you have to
go and subscribe so for nine nine
you can subscribe to daily wire comm go
over and check it out right now over at
daily wire DICOM you get the rest of
today shall live on video you also will
get Andrew Clavin show live on video
that is 10:30 today Pacific time you get
michael Knowles's show live on video at
12:30 today Pacific time
we're always presenting new comment new
new content for our subscribers the
Shapiro store is on the way that will be
discounts available for subscribers and
promising this for two years this is a
promise that will materialize so it's
gonna happen I know that for a fact
already getting the gear set up so and
get all that plus if you're an annual
subscriber for 99 bucks a year you got
all of those things plus the greatest of
all beverage vessels the leftist here's
hot or cold vessel now there are some
who have said that the fact that says
leftist Cheers hot or cold means that
I'm just being partisan I don't think
partisanship is relevant I think
principles are above partisanship but we
can still laugh at leftism because
leftism is stupid so leftist here's hot
or cold mug you can get that when you go
over to daily wire comm and get our
annual subscription or please subscribe
at YouTube you can watch the show for
free up to the point where we break and
then listen to the rest for free or you
can go over to SoundCloud or iTunes
subscribe leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
this sort of all this matters is the
fight mentality that I think it's really
corrupting the country I talked about it
a little bit in reference to george w
bush's speech last week I thought Bush's
speech was a quite normal good decent
defense of constitutional conservatism
and I think that people felt insulted
because they are so in entranced with
this with this pardon chip pardon
partisan bickering now how does it
matter beyond the social capital how
does it matter beyond the fact we don't
trust one another how does it matter
that we don't have a common set of facts
so one of the things that I think has
contributed to the fact that we don't
have a common set of facts are the media
because the media have conflated their
own opinions with their perception of
the facts so I'm going to show you a new
CNN ad it's an amazing ad from CNN that
I want to show you that just came out on
Twitter today and I want to show you how
you know even in an attempt to
quote-unquote build social capital the
media are being dishonest so here's CNN
saying facts are fact right they're
basically ripping off our slogan here at
the ben shapiro show they're ripping off
my personal catchphrase i have like a
sitcom catchphrase facts don't care
about your feelings but here is the
here's CNN basically ripping that off in
this ad so it's a picture of an apple
this is an apple some people might try
to tell you that it's a banana
they might scream banana banana banana
over and over and over again they might
put banana in all caps you might even
start to believe that this is a banana
but it's not this is an apple
and then says facts first CNN okay so I
have a pretty obvious problem with this
you know when you're saying not because
I don't think facts first
I do think facts first my problem is
when you conflate your opinion with the
facts you got a problem what I've been
trying to do and I've really been making
an effort is present the facts as I see
them and then present my opinion and you
can see okay if my opinion is right or
wrong
I'll give you my sourcing everyone who
emails me will ask him for sources I
always give them sources so that they
know whether where I'm getting my facts
here's the promise unit CNN says an
apple is an apple but then CNN on
headline news if I say a man is a man
and a woman is a woman I will be
physically assaulted on CNN Headline
News like when I say a banana it turns
out is still a banana then presumably
it's a problem right cNN has been doing
this sort of stuff for a while I mean
CNN runs this ad and they legitimately
have on you know on their website right
now there is a headline that reads this
okay this is the headline on there was a
story from 2017 June 2017 about a trans
man expecting first child like a trans
man you should read woman it's a woman
who's been taking hormone treatment that
gives this woman a beard basically and
had breast surgery to reduce the breasts
and it says my body is awesome trans man
expecting first child and then they say
an apple is an apple that is a woman I
mean for purposes of this the only
reason it turns out that woman gives
birth to child is not a story so CNN
pursues its narrative by skewing the
facts if you're going to claim that
there's a hard divide between objective
facts and opinion if you're gonna claim
that certain things are outright false
and certain things are outright true you
cannot conflate opinion in fact you
cannot say that your opinion is a fact
okay so there's another thing that's
contributing to the rise in partisanship
we can't even agree on the fact so we
can't agree on principles that we can't
agree on facts anymore and if we do
agree on principles then we have to go
partisan over it how does this have an
impact beyond just the loss of social
capital it has a pretty significant
impact in in terms of how the government
is run so while we're all busy slapping
each other silly over issues where we
largely agree like rape is bad sexual
assault is bad sexual harassment is bad
right because we're too eager to defend
politicians on our side because you know
it's easy for us to look at Penn State
and say why did all those people look
the other way how dare they look the
other way at Penn State but then we look
the other way when it's our institution
that's under fire or we say to the
Catholic Church how did you guys look
the other way on child abuse but then if
it's in inside our institutions we look
the other way okay this is true in a lot
of religious communities too okay then
we have to recognize that that destroys
the society but it also means that we
are we are going to ignore actual things
happening on the ground so to take an
example what happened in Niger in Niger
and I still can't pronounce this
properly I'm gonna look it up after the
show well what happens in Niger
the killing of four American soldiers in
Niger there were two separate senators
who came out and announced they had no
idea that we even had troops in Niger
okay Chuck Schumer who's the Senate
Minority Leader and Lindsey Graham who
is on the foreign policy subcommittee
Lindsey Graham both of them said I
didn't even know the United States has
troops in Niger troops have been in
Niger since 2013 Barack Obama wrote a
letter to the to the Congress saying I'm
putting troops in Niger in 2013 Stephen
Miller has a great piece on this over at
over at foxnews.com says US Special
Forces arrived in Niger in January 2013
on the orders of President Obama
they were then followed by about a
hundred military personnel and advisors
with the intention of conducting
unmanned reconnaissance missions over
Mali in conjunction with French military
forces a reuters reported in February
2013 that France intervened in Mali
so we've had troops there for years
right but the Congress didn't even know
because they're not doing their jobs
they're too busy engaging in the
partisan hackery and the partisan
hackery goes something like this if
Obama approved the troops in Niger the
left goes yay and if true if Trump
approved the troops in Niger then the
right goes yay but at no point does
anyone say should there be troops in
Niger and maybe Congress should have
voted on this thing rather than just
using the broad authorization for use of
military force from 2001 in order to
give the go-ahead to these sorts of
things all of this has some pretty
significant consequences for our society
for how our government works it's a
problem okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things I like I was encouraged by my
adoptive son and producer Mathis Glover
to go see Blade Runner in 20 49 over the
weekend now Mathis and I have a good
crossover in terms of the movies that we
like generally we have some
disagreements about Ridley Scott but
Mathis said this morning that the reason
this movie is good is because it's not
Ridley Scott he's
solutely correct Ridley Scott is wildly
overrated in any case Blade Runner 2049
is a significantly significantly better
film than the original Blade Runner a
lot better like Blade Runner the
original is basically valium it's visual
valium so there it's got a cool look to
it although it looks really dated now if
you watch it it's very hard to watch
with a straight face I know people are
in love with the original Blade Runner I
know that a lot of people are just they
they think it's just the most glorious
film they've watched the director's cut
and the second director's cut and the
third director's cut and the grips cut
they've watched all of these things but
I do not like the original Blade Runner
I've watched it twice each time I think
why do I not like this movie ok this
verb is in the new Blade Runner which is
not directed by Ridley Scott is directed
by Dennis Villanueva who is a very
talented director who made a rival which
I also recommended on the show he made
Blade Runner 2049 here's some of the
preview it is a very you know scientific
materialist view of the universe
basically then what makes a human being
is your sense of your own consciousness
there's no such thing as a soul there's
no such thing as unique human beings
that androids can be people to basically
you know all of this is supposedly based
on the philip k dick story do do
Androids Dream of Electric Sheep one of
the things about philip k dick like
stephen king a lot of his a lot of his
stories are used as source material for
movies that have nothing to do with the
actual material the the original Blade
Runner has almost nothing to do with
that short story but in any case the
look of this movie is better than the
original the plot of the movie is better
than the original the acne in the movie
is better than the original it is very
long it is not it is not a setting that
you want to spend 2 hours and 45 minutes
in because it's very dark it's it's film
the wash right that was the remote of
the original film but here's here's the
preview
[Music]
every civilization
was built off the back of a disposable
workforce but I can only make so many
happy birthday there is an order to
things
[Music]
that's what we do here
or keep order
the world is built on a wall that
separates kindness
tell either side there's no wall
you bought a war okay so I mean the
entire premise of the film is basically
are these androids people or are these
androids just Androids the film is
incredibly cool-looking it's a really
great-looking film and there's a bunch
of kind of sub areas of the film that
are really interesting like Ryan
Gosling's character who's in Android in
the film or at least that's what you
think at the very beginning I'm not
gonna give it away but Andrew but but
his character basically is in love with
his iPhone essentially there's a female
character who is created by a
corporation to basically be what a man
wants to be and over time it it
basically becomes to own personality
against own personality and almost
gained sentience if you want to see a
better version of that subplot go see
the movie her which is a really
interesting film with Joaquin Phoenix
that's it's quite fascinating about this
exact story online but the but the film
is really cool to look at Harrison Ford
turns in his only good performance in
the last 15 years
I mean Harrison form in this movie is
what Harrison Ford should have been in
force awakens if force awakens had been
a good film which it is not there are a
couple things that I think are cool
about this film that people haven't
noticed that are really neat so people
are saying well why is it called Blade
Runner 2049 obviously the world isn't
gonna look like 2049 by this point it is
obviously an alternative history you can
see that right in the film even in the
preview there's a graphic of a ballerina
dancing and it says Soviet happy CCCP so
meaning that the Soviet Union is still
around in this version of reality and
Blade Runner 2049 a critique that I saw
from Kevin Williamson of National Review
that I liked a lot as he said that
there's this weird notion on the left
that corporations are gonna take over
the world and run everything and it's
gonna be really oppressive and terrible
name a corporation that's done that
right corporations have made the world
significantly better like you're
complaining about Google Google is what
allows you to do all the cool things
you're doing right now like you can't
like all of the corporations we may not
like how they run and that's why we
actually expect them to run more like
public utilities when it comes to
providing services to everyone those I
think are real fears about corporations
but the idea that the corporations are
gonna take over and buy human beings and
use them as chattel and all this kind of
stuff I don't see a lot of evidence of
that corporations people are suspicious
of them its governments that do these
sorts of things not corporations unless
those corporations are basically being
run by governments most of most of the
evil corporations of the past have been
government-run or government-owned ok
time for a couple of things that I hate
ok so we begin with the UK government
has now announced that it wants the
United Nations to stop using the term
pregnant women in a UN treaty why
because it excludes trans people okay
this is idiotic women are the only ones
who can be pregnant
you know what defines a woman the lack
of a y-chromosome end of story we are
done that is all okay that's all we're
done okay when people talk about gender
being separate from sex what they're
suggesting is that sex doesn't
necessarily determine your attributes in
terms of feminine or masculine but that
just means feminine or masculine the
attempt to say that a feminine man is
actually a woman or a masculine woman is
actually a man is idiotic and if people
are intersex right they have two sets of
genitals which happens on very rare
cases or they have Klinefelter's
syndrome for example then you would say
this is a man with Klinefelter syndrome
if speaking a scientifically is foolish
trans men are not women okay and the
idea that trans men are pregnant is
ridiculous a woman is pregnant
it is a man with a mental disorder known
as gender dysphoria another a bunch of
people who've been saying well the DSM
says gender dysphoria isn't a mental
disorder the DSM is heavily politicized
dsm-4 called a gender identity disorder
and said it was a mental illness gender
dsm-5 based on no additional evidence
none zero zip zilch decided that instead
of saying that it was in and of itself a
mental disorder instead we would say
that it was not a mental disorder was
only the depression associated with
gender dysphoria that was a mental
disorder which has no logic to it that's
like saying schizophrenia is not a
mental disorder it is only a mental
disorder if you are depressed because
you are schizophrenic right or it's more
like saying that you have a body
dysmorphia issue that you're anorexic
for example and that is not actually a
mental disorder it's only a mental
disorder if you if you're depressed
because of it right then that's
foolishness in any case to redo all of
the to read you all treaties because
we're gonna pretend men aren't men and
women aren't women is absolutely asinine
I know and you know in the mode of
absolutely asinine Katie Couric who I
don't know why she's still relevant or
why she's around Katie Couric is going
around now
covers gender for National Geographic I
guess she's doing National Geographic
has decided to basically do clickbait
and that clickbait it's gonna be how
children are actually not boys or girls
they're actually genderless generalist
balls of cells and Katie Couric is going
to illuminate this for us and dirt and
what determines it how can someone sex
at birth
their Anatomy be different than their
gender identity I decided to get some
straight talk about gender I first saw
Sam killerman giving a TEDx talk Sam has
been studying gender for more than ten
years and he even wrote a book about it
okay so first of all it's called the
social justice advocates guide to gender
that means it's not scientific social
justice advocate means here is my
perspective and now I'm gonna try and
cram the facts into this particular box
again when I talk about partisanship
this is it okay there are certain
scientific facts everything that I have
said in the past five minutes is a
scientific fact you can disagree on the
interpretation of those facts but those
things are facts to pretend that they
are not is to be scientifically ignorant
but that is exactly what the media do on
a regular basis this angers me to no end
because again it prevents us from having
actual conversations about things that
are happening and that is in turn going
to destroy our capacity to have
political conversations it's just
foolishness
okay we will be back here tomorrow I
hope that we will have moved beyond the
Goldstar Widow story because I would
like to see some dignity restored to
American public life on every side
that's not a critique specifically up
front on every side that would be great
but I have little faith that will happen
so that's why we'll be here tomorrow
covering it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]